[Musique]
l'arlésienne dans un écrin celui du
théâtre montansier c'est la cinquième
édition du stage de l' orchestre avec
cette année à sa tête constante en rut
chef d'orchestre de l'opéra de massy qui
a choisi de leur faire jouer de la
musique de scène musique de scène on a
pris ça d'une manière extrêmement large
la musique de scène c'est la musique
pour qu'ils accompagnent le théâtre donc
on a la musique de l'arlésienne de bizet
qui accompagne le théâtre la musique de
scène c'est aussi la danse évidemment
avec la le tchaïkovski et la valse des
fleurs
la musique de scène c'est aussi le
cinéma aujourd'hui donc on a un petit
clin d'oeil à terme ce depuis lundi ils
répètent assidûment aux instruments des
musiciens en apprentissage les élèves de
second cycle des conservatoires de
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
mi mars on affichait déjà un déchiffrage
tous ensemble maintenant c'est vrai que
le travail
du restant de la semaine par parrot par
pupitre par instrument ça va être un
projet important pour pour les pour les
détails là aujourd'hui et du coup on
s'est revus pour répéter le morceau je
les connais ces semences à des points et
ça dépend des morceaux aux lyonnais qui
sont plusieurs que le bizet tchaïkovski
ou encore beethoven résonneront ce
vendredi les musiciens n'attendent plus
que vous pour valser
[Musique]